voudrais demander déjà ce qu'il ya des
enfants dans la salle les enfants de de
coulon ec3 je vais pouvoir raconter une
histoire et cette histoire je vais
l'introduire avec une citation que
personnellement j'adore cette citation
elle vient d'antoine de saint-exupéry
elle commence comme ceci si tu veux
construire un bateau ne rassemble pas
tes hommes et des femmes pour leur dire
quoi faire leur expliquer chaque détail
si tu veux construire un bateau fait
naître dans le coeur de ces hommes et
ces femmes l'envi de la mer le désir de
la maire ok désir de la mer l'envi envie
d'avoir envie
ça y est j'ai trouvé en fait la vie est
un voyage dans lequel nous nous
embarquons et dont on doit avoir envie
de vivre chaque jour d'expérience
d'exploration avec joie alors je suis
très mal poli je vais d'abord me
présenter
tu es line benoît je suis coach en
créativité et en fait j'accompagne les
entreprises à développer leur créativité
et donc l'organisent d'été des
séminaires et des team building et en
fait j'ai eu mon premier choc
le premier choc premier constat ça a été
de voir des adultes
pauvre créativité avec un muscle
complètement atrophiée les gens complexé
mais alors qu'est ce qui se passe c'est
ma fonction c'est mon activité
comment je vais faire et surtout j'ai
commencé à me questionner et s'y passe
comme ça
retenez bien j'adore le et si et si au
lieu d'avoir des adultes justement
complexé on avait des adultes
décomplexée heureux force de proposition
c'est à dire avec plein d'idées qui
rendrait un monde meilleur
en remontant dans ma réflexion je vais
encore plus loin c'est et si au lieu
d'avoir
des adultes on avait des grands enfants
et c'est tout naturellement que mon
activité s'est recentré auprès des
enfants
j'accompagne les enfants aujourd'hui à
développer leur créativité en leur
proposant des ateliers dont je vous
parlerai plus tard et ses enfants on va
en parler deux secondes
cette génération z c'est à dire
génération vous êtes comme ça pète z qui
veut aller vite
z qui sautent les modes d'emploi une
génération z qui est à développer cette
particularité en réponse en fait aux
problématiques de notre siècle le monde
va vite
le monde change vite et donc c'est tout
naturellement que des enfants ont
développé ces comportements alors certes
ça procure des montagnes russes aussi en
termes d'émotions mais toujours est il
qu'il ya un peu plus d'un an
nous y sommes cinq à avoir tenté
l'expérience tenter l'expérience
justement d'accompagner ses enfants avec
une vision une quête et cette quête
c'est une quête de trésors et une
méthode
et finalement il ya quelqu'un qui résume
très bien ce que nous souhaitions faire
la vision que nous souhaitions
poursuivre c ur cela le gain qui dit un
adulte créatif est un enfant qui a
survécu
ben oui ça tombe de sens et pour ce
faire on a un plan the biplan le plan
écoutez l'histoire c'est un on découvre
un trésor
et si pour découvrir seul trésor on
développait justement l'appétit
d'apprendre de ses enfants en leur
fournissant des outils les bonnes clés à
travers nos méthodes
on y apporte justement la technologie
dont ses enfants sont friands sont
gourmands alors quand je parle de
technologie
je prends juste c'est d'électronique
c'est la robotique c'est de l'impression
3d mais c'est aussi de la fabrication
artisanale et surtout locker la
créativité mais c'est pas que des outils
et avant tout pour que ça marche une
pédagogie
parce que si les outils déclenché un
savoir faire la pédagogie elle va
travailler le savoir être et au final je
peux vous en parler que la posture du
créatif c'est avant tout un savoir être
je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure des
adultes complexe et c'est peut-être le
frein notre propre créativité
la créativité est là pour tout le monde
c'est comme un muscle plus vous le
pratiquez plus vous devez vous devenez
pardon vous devenez rapide vous allez
forme il est beaucoup plus d'idées c'est
pas tant que moi je suis aux plus
créatifs que les autres c'est que le
pratiquent plus souvent et que j'ai eu
cette curiosité pour ça c'est juste la
distinction
je n'ai pas plus de créativité que les
autres et donc ce savoir être on a
enlevé la technique de nos outils
technologiques on veut pas en faire des
ingénieurs
on veut juste que l'enfant se
concentrent se recentre et à chercher le
trésor en lui sa propre créativité qui
puisse apporter justement les idées sont
terro son adn et qu'ils puissent se
découvrir lui-même pour ma part j'ai des
enfants trois qui sont aussi de la
génération z des enfants geek qui sont
mordus fans des jeux vidéo et j'ai fait
l'erreur - tant que maire justement
d'aller la chasse aux tablettes jeudi
erreur parce que je me suis vite rendu
compte qu'au final ça marchait pas et
que j'étais en train d'appliquer mon
propre modèle éducatif l'éducation que
moi j'ai reçu à ce moment là mais la
réalité ce que ces enfants ils sont nés
avec des tablettes est donc le deuxième
choc que j'ai eu la deuxième grande
question
ça a été de nous poser la question tout
simplement
excusez moi je vais vite des fois ça a
été de vous poser la question et si au
lieu d'aller contre on faisait avec et
d'ailleurs vous pouvez réfléchir dans
votre vie ce soit professionnel ou vie
privée cette formule m fonctionne
vachement bien et si au lieu d'aller
contre on fait avec
ça enlève la première chose c'est la
peur la peur de l'inconnu et donc
forcément
envie d'avoir envie le désir d'apprendre
lorsqu'on est motivé pour aller vers
quelque part on n'est pas motivé pour
échapper à quelque chose on n'est pas
dans la peur justement moi j'aurai une
critique
à cet égard au niveau de l'éducation de
l'école ce que l'école va nourrir des
compétences des savoirs mais qu'en
est-il de l'individu où est la place de
l'individu
pour en revenir à mon histoire des
enfants de la génération z
quand je vous disais qu'ils savaient
sweepé avant même de savoir marcher
c'est des enfants qui n'ont pas besoin
de mode d'emploi ce sont des enfants qui
effectivement ont besoin d'aller vite au
détriment parfois justement d'aller
chercher ce qu'il ya derrière la boîte
noire de se questionner alors dans cette
consommation passive
parce que c'est ça qui me dérange c'est
que mes enfants jouent aux jeux vidéo de
façon passive et dans cette consommation
passive
comment on peut les faire devenir acteur
est tout simplement je me suis dit bas
pour de faire pour devenir acteur il
faut être en action la démonstration
c'est quand éveillant la curiosité on
enlève le mode passif on et merveilles
est passé de la curiosité
l'émerveillement à l'action en
fabriquant en prototype en tout de suite
ce qu'il ya derrière votre tête ne
cherche pas la performance vous voyez
que les prototypes sont pas tout à fait
finalisé mais on s'en fiche l'enfant il
est fier c'est pô le parent il est fier
aussi
et c'est surtout qu'il a développé des
solutions il ya ingénieux il est
astucieux il utilise le moindre bout de
ficelle ça y est on tient quelque chose
et lorsqu'il fabricant lorsqu ils
fabriquent des objets il se passe une
troisième interactions hyper
intéressante c'est que l'enfant va avoir
envie de partager ils réfléchissent
ensemble le cerveau collectif se met en
oeuvre
c'est à dire qu'on est passé de l'étape
d'individus d'individuation je sois pas
le dire mais c'est pas
à la partie collective bah oui tant qu'à
faire
j'ai un savoir-faire et un savoir-être
autant le faire savoir ce qui a pour but
d'atteindre l'empowerment ckoi
l'empowerment c'est justement la
découverte pour soi de sa capacité à
sion l'enfant s'émancipe se découvre des
talents se découvrent des super pouvoirs
et ses super pouvoirs
on va lui demander encore un petit peu
plus parce qu'on me dit tant qu'à faire
puisque tu sais faire quelque chose
aujourd'hui il faut que tu le fasses
savoir est-ce que tu serais capable
d'expliquer ton projet on voudrait
boucler la boucle célébrer cette
compétence que tu as ses super pouvoirs
que le monde le sache
et c'est bien volontiers là nous avons
augustin qui a 8 ans qui a pris le micro
et devant le public et devant ses
parents surtout il a expliqué son projet
est très bien il l'a fait avec des
tailles minutie beaucoup de précision et
beaucoup de joie je peux pas vous dire
le regard des parents à quel point il
pétille à ce moment là mais ils ont
découvert un super héros transformation
normalement c'est nous qui sommes pour
modèle les enfants nous prennent pour
modèle nous les adultes et ben là je
peux vous dire que c est l inverse
alors voilà les d'ateliers que nous
menons on appelle ça des espaces de
libération et de fabrication des idées
et c'est pas pour rien qu'on a choisi
d'ailleurs le nom trésorier hommes c'est
l'espace des trésors nous sommes à la
recherche des pépites de vos trésors et
dans tous nos ateliers
on va n'avoir de cesse que d'aller
chercher l'enthousiasmé il faut qu'ils
soient ludiques
il faut qu'on ait veille je vous ai je
vous ai dit tout à leur donner envie
d'avoir envie
c'est le premier saut quantique et la
deuxième c'est de parler le même langage
je ne vais pas parler à de la même façon
un enfant de six ans qu'elle suit 13 ans
tout simplement parce qu'ils n'ont pas
les mêmes intérêts non plus et donc à
linverse de l'école nous adaptons notre
langage mais aussi on laisse l'enfant se
planter et oui ces machins
pourquoi parce que quand dix plants
cherchent ils cherchent hirschi cherche
et cherche et on laisse chercher et un
moment il trouve alors que ce soit lui
ou un autre enfant qui est venu lui dire
l'interaction elle intéressante on
laisse faire et lorsqu'il a trouvé qu
est ce qu il fait il partage et la
boucle est bouclée
si bien que dans cette boucle il aura
trois facteurs essentiels dans son
développement personnel qui sont la
persévérance puisqu'il a cherché et
qu'il a trouvé
il a développé une aptitude persévérante
lui de la génération z zapette
la deuxième c'est l'autosatisfaction
daoui la trouver et en plus ils en
parlent
alors c'est génial parce que ça
s'appelle de l'estimé de soi tout ça est
clairement faire des supers adultes et
d'ailleurs les grands les adultes moi
j'appelle les grands enfants les adultes
ne s'y trompent pas et nous réclament
les ateliers ils veulent en faire partie
et en haut à gauche
d'ailleurs vous avez de
l'intergénérationnel c'est très
intéressant nous avons le fils le père
et le grand-père qui sont venus à
l'atelier à égalité la technique ou la
culture sont à égalité et se partager se
fusionnent alors si ces enfants-là et
grands enfants ça va passer merci coach
et si ses enfants non ça ne passe pas
merci
et pourtant non 60 en 2025 je reprends
en 2025 l'état le ministère du travail
américain prédit que 65% des métiers
n'existe pas encore alors on peut
imaginer effectivement dangereux
je me suis dit 'il y aura des grenades
rda petit fils goût de manager alors ça
vous parle pas c'est du jargon c'est
normal ça n'existe pas encore par contre
l'enjeu si on réfléchi à ça c'est qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire pour qu'on soit prêt
en 2025 pour ces nouveaux métiers
quel type d'enfant étudiants apprenant
pouvons-nous justement préparé à ça et
moi j'ai une vision
j'ai un rêve moi mon rêve c'est d'en
faire des petits léonard de vinci
des petits léonard de vinci doté de
super pouvoirs
parce que mine de rien en apprenant à
faire de ces erreurs aussi
en enrichissant sa culture sa curiosité
en développant des techniques
tout comme léonard de vinci comme n'y
réfléchis il était à la fois sculpteur
architecte biologiste peintre il avait
tout un tas d'aptitude
il avait des super pouvoirs et si dans
nos ateliers nous en faut aussi avait
des super pouvoirs pour demain répondre
aux problématiques de façon rapide
éclairé et responsable et bien sûr
créative voulez savoir quel était le
secret de leonard de vinci pour
atteindre justement ces différentes
aptitudes il développé
ajoie dans chaque chose de la curiosité
dans chaque chose et de l'émerveillement
dans chaque chose est d'ailleurs dit moi
c'est quand la dernière fois que vous
vous êtes émerveillé quand bon à part ce
soir était facile et moins sain
j'étais super mentor qui m'ont qui me
l'ont appris des professeurs émérites
si les enfants mes enfants mes super
héros c'est eux que je prend pour modèle
pour me rappeler justement à quel point
il est essentiel pour nous d'avoir de la
joie de la curiosité l'émerveillement
dans toutes choses et mes enfants ont
d'ailleurs ils sont plus il dit que ça
et moi ils m'ont apporté une belle
surprise
ah oui parce que petite parenthèse
souvent satan ou surprises auxquelles on
s'attend pas une surprise
un peu con et donc ils m'ont apporté une
belle surprise
on était une manifestation culturelle il
devait faire un atelier de fusées bref
et en une dizaine maman on devrait bien
faire le concours de cuisine par dont il
n'avait jamais eu d'intérêt pour la
cuisine si ce n'est posé leurs pieds
sous la table et manger n'avait il
n'avait jamais manipulé une paire de
ciseaux ou de couteau pour cuisiner d'où
vient cet intérêt soudain mais en fait
ils sont découverts des super pouvoirs
ils se disent je suis capable maintenant
ils ont essayé et effectivement et vous
savez quoi ils ont gagné le concours
face à des adultes
c'était une belle surprise et voilà ce
qu'ils m'ont rappelé c'est que aussi il
ne faut jamais cesser de vouloir rester
créatif de jouer que vous considérez
votre vie comme un terrain de jeu chaque
jour de ne pas vous donne à voir aucun
complexe et aujourd'hui je voudrais
qu'en cet instant ici maintenant on
fasse une ovation pour les enfants pour
les encourager à rester créatif afin que
demain on est des adultes créatif
épanouie responsable éclairé et qui nous
fasse un super monde
est ce que vous êtes ok pour ça donc on
se donne 30 secondes vous faites ce que
vous voulez vous faites sur tous vos
enfants si vous avez envie mais moi je
vous le conseille donc a321 ovation pour
les enfants sans merci pour eux